[موسيقى]
على 8:00 بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياضه صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
حمله القمع الايرانيه تشتد في الداخل
وتشتاز الحدود وابنه شقيقه خامنئي تحضر
العالم من التعامل مع النظام
نهائي ام مبكر للمونديال في مباراه
المانيا اسبانيا والمغرب يبث الفرح بفوزه
على بلجيكا ويقترب من دور السته عشر
على السلاح الاوكراني يثقل كاهل اوروبا
استنفذت مخزونها من الدعم العسكريه وروسيا
في خطر ايضا
تركيا تساعده هجماتها شمال سوريا وتصمم
على الاستمرار والاكراد يتظاهرون احتجاجا
على الصمت الدولي
[موسيقى]
وسعتم اوقاتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
نبداوها من ايران وعلى ما يبدو ان مقتل
شعبه الكرديه مثلا سبتمبر الماضي كان
كفيلا لليهود قاعده النظام الايراني
الهشاشه منذ شهرين لم تخلو شوارع المدن
الايرانيه من المحتاجين
اتت لتفجر ما يخبئه الشعب داخله من ضمن
واستبداد وبزخ من اكثر عاده انتفاضه
الجامعات والتسعه الاضرابات وفي المقابل
تصاعدت حمله القمع والعنف ولا اعتقالات
واكثر من ذلك هدد الحرس الثوري والمحتجين
باكثر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
دعوه لافته وجهتها فريده مراد خاني ابنه
شقيقه مرشد النظام الايراني
ودعم الشعب وفي الفيديو الذي انتشر اليوم
قالت ابنته شقيقه خامنئي ان الايرانيين
يخوضون حربا مع السلطات
اي انسان
حتى تتوقف حكوماتكم عن دعم هذا النظام
قاتل الاطفال هذا النظام لا يلتزم باي من
المبادئ الدينيه ولا يعرف قانون ولا قاعده
للحكم سوى القوه والمال ليحافظ على سلطته
باي طريقه ممكنه
حان الوقت لتقوم جميع البلدان الحره
والديمقراطيه بحركه رمزيه عن طريق استدعاء
جميع ممثليها من ايران وطرد كل منتسب لهذا
النظام الوحشي كطريقه للتعبير عن التضامن
مع الشعب الايراني
وفي اخر ضحايا الاحتجاج جراء حمله قمع
النظام افاد موقعه وهران لحقوق الانسان
بانه من تاريخ السادس عشر من سبتمبر حتى
الخامس والعشرين من نوفمبر قتل النظام ما
لا يقل عن 448 متظاهرا بينهم نحو 63 طفلا
دون 18 من العمر خلال الاحتجاجات على
مستوى البلاد في ايران وبحسب بيان مجموعه
نشطاء حقوق الانسان في ايران فقد تم
اعتقاله ما لا يقل عن
18,000,170 متظاهرا يذكر في التقرير ايضا
انه تم اعتقاله 565 اطالبا وطالبه في 240
جامعه كانت مصر حل لتجمعات لطلابيه
الاحتجاجيه خلال ذات الفتح
تختار ايه
[موسيقى]
19 يا باشا
[تصفيق]
وحمله القمعه التي يمارسها النظام لم
تقتصر على الداخل الايراني فقط بل وصلت
الملاحقات الى دول عده هيئه الاذاعه
الكنديه افادت بان ايرانيين يحملون
الجنسيه الكنديه يتعرضون للتهديد
والمراقبه من قبل اعضاء متابعينا للنظام
الايراني موجودين في كندا الهيئه واضافت
ان بعضها هؤلاء المعارضين ابلغوها انهم
تلقوا تهديدات عبر مكالمات هاتفيه رسائل
نصيه واشار الى ان هذه الرسائل حذرتهم من
تناول الاوضاع في ايران عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي
معنى من اصله عمار كسائي عضو منظمه حقوق
الانسان الاحوازيه عمار اهلا بكم معنا في
اخبار الساعه ما مدى خطوره ومدى جديه كذلك
هذه التهديدات التي يتلقاها الايرانيون في
الخارجين الكرام بطبيعه الحال هذه ليست
تهديدات وهناك النظام الايراني لديه ااا
يعني ثوابت كثيره في تنفيذ حتى الاغتيالات
بحق الناشطين وبحق الصحفيين
والدول الاوروبيه اعتقلت عدد من المرتبطين
بالنظام الايراني في عده دول
وان هناك الكثير من
الناشطين الذين راحوا ضحايا هذه
الاغتيالات التي سارت همم وحدثت على ارض
همم اوروبا همم هذه حقيقيه وحتى
بعد التهديدات التي اطلقها ايران ضد
الصحفيين مثلا
وحدات من الشرطه البريطانيه ترابط
الفارسيه في لندن نعم وايضا هناك رسائل
تصل للكثير من الناشطين وكما همم تفضلتم
في في تقرير نعم كما تفضلت هذه التهديدات
خطيره ويعني ممارسات النظام الايراني في
هذا الموضوع يعني له ثوابق فيها السلطات
الايرانيه همم تصف هذه الاحتجاجات بانها
اعمال شغب وتتهم الغرب بالتحريض عليها هل
تعتقد ان النظام الايراني يمكن ان يقدم
على تنفيذ ان كان عمليات خطف او عن حتى
عمليه اغتيال في الدول الغربيه
نعم يعني هناك قبل فتره قبل سنه اعتقد او
هكذا
انه نعتم الكشف عن مؤامره لخطف ناشطه من
امريكا وايضا تم خط بعض الناشطين من الدول
المجاوره لايران اما ان يقومون بخطف ناشط
او ناشطه من الدول الاوروبيه اعتقد من
ناحيه امكانيه امكانيه تنفيذ هذا يبدو صعب
ولكن النظام الايراني في الماضي وقبل
الاحتجاجات قام باغتيال الكثير من ال ال
الناشطين في المانيا وفي هولندا وفي
الكثير من وفي ايطاليا والكثير من الدول
الاوروبيه الان لا اعتقد انه يصعب على
النظام الايراني تنفيذ مثل هذه
التهديدات طيب اسال عمار هذا عن خارج
ايران اما دخل ايران حمله القمع مستمره
وتنذر بما هو اسوا على ما يبدو هناك
المزيد من احكام الاعدام ما الذي تمكنت
منظماتكم من راسته
يعني نحن تمكنا من توثيق الكثير من حالات
الاغتيال او حالات السقوط الضحايا او
اطلاق الرصاص الحي او اعتقال الناشطين او
الحكم بالاعدام
بحق مثلا عساكر عباس عساكر الذي هو احد
الشهود الموجودين على مجزره محشور التي
حدث في عام 2019
وقيل او يقال قتل في هذه المجزره اكثر من
200 شخص وهي في مدينه محشور فيها الاحوال
وايضا ايضا هناك لدينا بعض
الاتصالات مع ذوي وعوائل الضحايا كما ان
المنظمات التي تعمل معنا
الحقوقيه من الايرانيه والكرديه وغيرها
التي ترتبط الشعوب ايضا لديها توفيق
وسوف يقول لنا عمل مع ايضا مع لجنه تخصص
الحقائق
نعم اشكركم شكرا جزيلا من اوسلو حدثتمونا
عمار كسائي عضو منظمه حقوق الانسان
الاحوزيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في اوكرانيا تطورات
الميدانيه بطيئه اتهامات متبادله والشتاء
يحل ضيفا ثقيلا عليها فمجريات الحرب باتت
تاخذ منحني انسانيه صعبا وروسيا لم تتاخر
لحظه في قصف وضرب نقطه ضعف البنا التحتيه
الى ماء او كهرباء لنحو 20 ساعه اصبح يعيش
اكثر من سته ملايين اسره في اوكرانيا
ووسائل التدفئه معدومه بحسب ما افاد
الرئيس
كارثه الخصوصا مع تساقط الثلوج ولم يعد
بيد سكني اوكرانيا حيله سوى ترشيد استهلاك
الكهربائي والمياه
المفقودين اصلا في وقت اعلنت اوكرانيا
استعاده نحوي 80% من محطه الكهرباء بعد
تعطلها بسبب القصف الروسي
[موسيقى]
هذا وافاد تقرير لهيئه الاركان العامه
للقوات المسلحه
تجري استعدادات للموجه التاليه من التعبئه
السريه في صفوف القوات الروسيه اعتبارا من
العاشر
من روسيا توصلوا اعاده تجميع قوتها لتعزيز
فرقها ووحداتها في اتجاهات عده
بالاضافه الى نقص قواتها تعاني روسيا ايضا
من شح في امدادات الاسلحه اوكرانيا ايضا
في خطر بالنسبه لهذا الامر حيث ان ثلثي
دول حلف الناتو استنفذت مخزوناتها من
الذخائر المدفعيه والجويه صحيفه نيو تايمز
قالت ان انجازات السلاح لاوكرانيا ودول خط
المواجهه كابولندا ودول البلطيق باتت عبئا
يثقل كاهل الحلف والاتحاد الاوروبي
اشهر تسعه مرت على الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا انهكت الطرفين بشكل واضح وافرغت
مخازن السلاح كما يبدو وحتى العزم الغربي
على مدى اوكرانيا بالسلاح وفقا نيويورك
والتناسب بين استهلاك الذخيره وانتاجها ما
تعكسيا الغرب لم يعد قادرا على الحفاظ على
الخط البياني للتغذيه العسكريه في ارتفاع
او حتى ثبت المخازن وتفرغ بينما روسيا
واوكرانيا تحرقان الاسلحه بوتيره لم يسبق
لها مثيل منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
ليرتبط مصير الحرب بالحفاظ على استمراريه
تدفق السلاح للطرفين
عدد الطلقات في اليوم الواحد في اوكرانيا
يعادل شهرا او اكثر في افغانستان تسريحات
مختلفه اطلقتها الولايات المتحده تصر على
ان مخزوناتها تسد الحاجه الاوكرانيه
الملحه في سبيل حمايه مصلحه امريكا في كل
مكان
نحن ملتزمون بتزويد اوكرانيا بما تحتاجه
في ساحه المعركه
اكثر يقترحها الغرب على دول اوروبا
الشرقيه كالعوده لمعدات الحقبه سوريا
واستثمار مصانع الاسلحه القديمه لاعاده
تصنيع الذخائر
روسيا ليست في حال افضل فهي ايضا تقتصد في
استهلاك الذخائر وتزيد الانتاج العسكري
رغم ذلك تتجه نحو حليفتيها لشراء الصواريخ
من كوريا الشماليه واستخدام المسيارات
الايرانيه الرخيصه الى عمر العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك معنا استاذ طارق هل هذا الحديث من
قبل نيته بان حرب اوكرانيا استنزفت
المخزونات العسكريه ينبا بان النيدو
سيتوقف عن دعم اوكراني عسكريا
مساء الخير يا سيدي وشكرا للاستضافه ابدا
هذا الحديث يؤكد ان هناك مشكله لها علاقه
بموضوع اللوجستي للوصول الى ما نسميه هذه
الذخائر التي يجب ان ترسل الى اوكرانيا
واؤكد بكلمه يجب بمعنى ان حلف الناتو
والبيئه المتحده الامريكيه معا اتفقاء ان
يكون هناك دعما عسكريا مهما اوكرانيا
ولذلك الان نحن امام ما يسمى اقتصاد حرب
بمعنى ان الدول عليها ان تبدا بدعم هذه
الشركات التي تنتج الذخائر
وتعطيها نوعا ما همم
الرياء ارتياح اقتصادي لكي تذهب بعيدا
لانه كما قلت حضرتك كما قال التقرير نحن
امام ما يسمى نوعا ما هذا الميزان العسكري
بقى بدا يعني يفقد همم المواجهه ما بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا ولو انه روسيا لا تزال
لديها كبيره وفي جميع الاحوال ما يحصل
الان هو تمهيد للاجتماع الناتو الذي سيكون
موجوده في رومانيا همم في في الايام
المقبله وهذا مهم لكي يعرف الجميع ان هذا
الاقتصاد يجب ان ترفع كل هذه الدول من
موازنه همم وزاره الدفاع التي هي
الاقتصاد
العسكري الاقتصاد بشكل عام هناك ملم
الاقتصادي لدى الشعوب الاوروبيه كذلك من
تبعات هذه الحرب الا يمكن ان يكون هذا في
اطار الضغط مره اخرى على همم كيف للذهاب
باتجاه الجلوس مع روسيا الى طاوله
المفاوضات لانهاء الحرب
سؤالك جد مهم لان الكل يعرف انه منذ بدء
الحرب منذ بدء ما نسميه مسانده اوكرانيا
والكل يعرف ان هناك ارتدادات سلبيه على
اوروبا باولا لانها هي في الجبهه هي هي
اول ما نسميه اول الارتدادات لهذه الحرب و
ااا
ما نشهده الان في اوروبا بموضوع الطاقه
والغذاء هو من هذه الارتداد المهمه ولكن
هذا رغم ان هناك جزء من المجتمع بدا يتافف
من هذه الحرب لا تزال لدى لدى الغرب عامه
الفكره المهمه ان كل ما يقوم به هو لدعم
ما نسميه الحريه لدعم ما نسمي الديمقراطيه
ويجب ان ندفع هذا الثمن الغالي الذي هو
دعم الحريه والديمقراطيه ولكن بنفس الوقت
يجب ان يكون هناك ما نسمى همم خطط وهذه
الخطط بدات فيها الاتحاد الاوروبي مثلا
بوضع حد او لاسعار الطاقه بدا
الدول التي هي بحاجه لمن نسميه اقتصاد
الحرب كما قلت لك ولذلك انا برايي رغم كل
هذا التعفف ستظل سيظل الغرب متجها نحو
اتجاه باتجاه دعم اوكرانيا لان هذا الدعم
لا يمكن ان يقف لانه كانت المحاوله في
اجتماع دول ال 20 ان يكون هناك طاوله حوار
وان يكون هناك ما نسميه مجلس الحكماء
فرنسا المملكه العربيه السعوديه الصين
وتركيا ولكن للاسف الشديد في اليوم التالي
ارسلت روسيا همم يعني امطرت روسيا
اوكرانيا بمئات الصواريخ وهذا لم يكن سهله
لقيام بهذا الموضوع شكرا جزيلا لكم المحلل
السياسي طارق وهبي كنت معنا مباشره من
باريس
[موسيقى]
وبعيدا عن الحرب الدائره في اوكرانيا ومن
اجل كتب تاييد اسيا وافريقيا برنامج
مساعده الغذائيه الدوليه يستهدف الدول
الاكثر فقرا رئيس الاوكراني
12 مليون طن من منتجات الحبوب الى اربعين
دوله مشيرا الى ان نحو 500 سفينه غادرت
الموانئ الاوكرانيه في اطار اتفاق شحن
الحبوب عبر البحر الاسود الذي وقع في
تركيا الامم المتحده برنامج المساعدات
الدوليه هدفه مواجهه الاتهامات الروسيه
لان الدول الغنيه في الغرب تسببت في ازمه
غذاء عالميه جراء العقوبات التي فرضتها
[موسيقى]
وانا اذهب الان الى الشمال السوريين اسبوع
لم تهدا فيه الضرباته التركيه على شمالي
سوريا غارات جويه حاليا
واصرار تركي مدى جليا في تصريحات رئيسها
رجب طيب اردوغان المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان افاد بان تركيا استهدفت مطار
العسكري وقرن بريف حلب الشمالي مستخدمه
الطيران الحربي والمسيرات الى جانب
المدفعيه خلال خمسه ايام من الغارات
الجويه التركيه قتل واصيب نحو مئه وخمسه
وعشرين شخصا من العسكريين والمدنيين وفي
تطورات المواجهات شمال سوريا ايضا اعلن
الاكراد السوريون واقطع عملياتهم ضد تنظيم
داعش في ظل الاستمرار التهديدات التركيه
كما اعلنت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه قصد
انها ستصدى لاي عمل بريه تركي
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان حذر من ان
لا احد يستطيع ان يمنع بلاده من استخدام
ما وصحه بحقها في الحفاظ على امن هذا داخل
وخارج حدودها واضاف اردوغان ان تركيا لها
حق التصرف في المناطق التي حددتها خارج
حدودها من اجل حمايتها
لتركيا الحب في التصرف داخل وخارج حدودها
في المناطق المحدده من اجل املها لا احد
يستطيع ان يمنعنا من ممارسه هذا الحق
الاكراد في مدينه القامشلي ممددينها
بعمليه وتهديدات انقره والصمت الدولي اذا
ما يحدث
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
انا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وانت
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واحاول الخبر العاجل الذي ورد قبل قليل
حيث افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان ان
القوات التركيه والفصائل المواليه لها
تقصف مواقع لقوات النظام في ريف الرقه في
شمال سوريا حول هذا التطور كذلك معنا من
مدير المرصده السوري رامي عبد الرحمن
استاذ رامي اهلا بكم معنا اذا قصف جديد
ايضا على الرقه ما الذي تمكنته من جمعهم
من معلومات حول هذا القصف التركي
حقيقه الامر في ريف تل ابيض الغربي في
الرقه الشمالي من قبل القوات التركيه على
الاقل هناك ثلاثه قرى تعرضت من قبل القوات
التركيه والفصائل لها هذا القصف لم يكن
الوحيد اليوم كان هناك قصه ايضا على
الرفعه والقرى في كره اخرى في ريف حلب
الشمالي وايضا كان هناك استهداف لمسيره
تركيا بلده في ريف حلب الشمالي ادت لمقتل
خمسه عناصر النظام واستهداف كره في الريف
الحسكه ولكن ايضا كان هناك استهداف ايضا
منطقه كوباني
بالرصاص من داخل الاراضي التركيه من ادى
لجرح تطلعي ان القصر عما الاراضي السوريه
على الحدود السوريه التركيه في اقصى شمال
الحسكه وصل الى شمال حلب هل هناك اي رد من
قوات النظام السوري على تركيا
قواعد التركيه في ريف حلب الشمالي من قبل
القوات النظام والقوات الكرديه هنا
للمشاهد حقيقه الامر في ريف حلب الشمالي
لا يوجد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
المتواجدين في ريف حلب الشمالي هم قوات
النظام وقوات كرديه او ما تعرف بقوات
تحرير العطريين التي لا علاقه لها مباشره
سوريا الديمقراطيه طيب كيف يفهم هذا انه
يعني تركيا هي تقول انها تقوم بهذا القصف
ردا على تفجير اسطنبول وهي تستهدف الاكراد
بشكل اساسي قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه كيف
تقرا استهدا لقوات النظام يعني هي تريد ان
تقول
لي قمصان لن تتواجد في هذه المناطق وفقا
لاتفاقيات روسيه تركيه في العام 2019
اعتقد بان الامر واضح للجميع وبالنسبه
لتفجير اسطنبول نحن يعني نعتقد منذ اللحظه
الاولى بانه عليه اشارات استفهام كثيره
واعتقد واكون جاما لا يمكن ان تكون قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه تقف وراء هذا التفجير
كي تشير تركيا لهذه المعركه التي يريدها
اردوغان طيب على ذكر هذه المعركه التي
يريدها الرئيس التركي استاذ رامي همم هناك
على ما يبدو استعدادات همم في همم المناطق
الكرديه خصوصا ل- اا هجوم بري تركي وشيك
ربما او محتمل هل لديكم اي معلومات اضافيه
اذا كان بالفعل اردوغان همم سينفذ هذه
الحمله البريه على شمال سوريا
بالنسبه للحمله البردي البريه عفوا هناك
الفصائل المولعه لتركيا حط اللحظه لا يوجد
استمطار على الاطلاق في صفوف هذه الفصائل
لا يوجد قوات تركيه وصلت الى الحدود الى
الان الحمله البريه التركيه هي حمله
اعلاميه هذا لا يعني بان الحمله لن تاتي
لان القرار يعود الى الرئيس التركي هو
صاحب القرار بتنفيذ العمليه من عدمه الى
الان يكتفي بالقصف البري يكتفيه بالقصف
الجوي ولكن حتى الطائرات الحربيه لم تعد
تعمل مثل اليوم الاول الذي اجتهدت الاراضي
السوريه بنحو 50 غاره عبد الرحمن المدير
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
الهجوم البريء الذي نتحدث عنه الذي تعده
انقره على شمال سوريا قد يفتح الباب على
مصراعيه لعوده تنظيم داعش مره اخرى الى
الواجهه تقرير
لصحيفتي واشنطن كشف ان ضربه تركيا للاكراد
قد يؤدي الى فراري نحو عشره الاف من عناصر
داعش المحتجزين حاليا لدى قوه سرديمقراطيه
الى نحو 50 دوله قرار هذه العناصر سيعبد
الطريق امام داعش لاعاده تنظيم صفوفه في
وقت تكون فيه قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه لا
تستطيع السيطره عليهم في ظل الهجمات
التركيه تقرير الصحيفه لم يستبعد ايضا
امكانيه حرب اقليميه بسبب الهجوم المحتمل
ضد الاكراد خصوصا انه هروب عناصر داعش
سيثير وقلق امريكا وحلفه
[موسيقى]
في العراق هجمات واعتداءات متكرره على
سياده العراق وايران تعد بالمزيد وربما
هجوم
الحرس الثوري على الحدود الشماليه
لم يتم ضبط الحدود ونشر القوات العراقيه
على طول شريط الحدوديه الامر الذي دفع
بغداد واربيل بالتنسيق بينهما وتشكيلي
لجان امنيه مهماتها الامساك وتامين الحدود
بعد الهجمات الايرانيه المتكرره داخل
اقليم كردستان العراق وبعد ان هدد الطيران
بغداد بنشر قواتها على طول الحدود بين
الجانبين او انها ستقوم بعمليات بريه داخل
العمق العراقي ضد من وصفتهم بالجماعات
المعارضه الايرانيه المسلحه سرعت بغداد
واربيل الخطى لايجاد حل عاجل لنزع فتي
للازمه
لقواتنا الامنيه بالتعاون والتنسيق مع
اخواننا في البيشمركه خاصه على طول شريط
الحدود بين العراق وتركيا وبين العراق
وايران طبعا الغايه من هذا التواجد
والتنسيق هو لمنع التسلل وايضا لمنع اي
هجم همم تحاول ان تعكر صفوها الامن
نشر هذه القوات جاء بعد اتفاق بين اربيل
وبغداد خلال زياره رئيس الاقليم لجيرفان
بارزاني الى العاصمه 9 حكومه المركز
دون تكرار الهجمات الايرانيه بالطائرات
المسيره والصواريخ التي تهدد ايران
بتحويلها الى عمليه بريه ما يهم اربيل وهو
يبعده خطر صواريخ ايران ومسيراتها
الانتحاريه عن اراضيها والامر مسحوب ايضا
على هجمات تركيا
اربيل قطع الشوطن طويله من المفاوضات مع
بغداد للاتفاق على نشر مزيد من قوات حرس
الحدود العراقي على شرطي حدودها مع ايران
وتركيا ترى هل يرى النور قريبا هذا
الاتفاقين الشيخ عسكري وامني واخر شخصيه
اي تقارب اربيل وبغداد سياسيه اما يتعلق
بهذا الملف لا اعتقد ان الملف العسكري
تواجد او يعني اعاده انتشاره قوات حرس
الحدود على شريط الحدود العراق التركي
الايراني
مع وتركيا مؤخرا الى ان طول الحدود وعورته
جبالها تحتاج ربما الى اضعاف هذا الرقم من
اربيل احمد الحمداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
لدينا بعد قليل تويتر هجره جماعيه لكن
ماسك متفائل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
لشركه تويتر
[موسيقى]
مقامره ماسك منصه كتويتر عرضتها لهجره
العقول وخساره المستخدمين هو الاخطر
خلافات مع افضل العلامات التجاريه
والمسوقين فالعهد المطرب لتويتر عرض قسم
الاعلانات لدى الشركه الذي يجني 5 مليارات
دولار سنويا الى ضربه قويه
جميع العلامات التجاريه الكبرى اوقفت
مؤقتنا الانفاق على تويتر مستشهدين بالجزع
من نهج ماسك بمراقبه المحتوى وفصل العديد
من فريق مبيعات الاعلانات قسم الاعلانات
بتويتر تعرض ايضا لضربه الموجعه بعد عده
موجات من عمليات الفصل والاستقالات ادت
لنقص حاد بالموظفين وباتت العديد من
الوكالات لا تملك نقطه اتصال مع تويتر
ماسك المرغم على اتمام صفقه تويتر يجد
نفسه تحت ضغوط تحقيق الارادات حيث يواجه
مدفوعات بفائده سنويه بقيمه مليار دولار
بعد تحميل الشريكه بدين قدره 13 مليار
دولار للمساعده في تمويل استحواذه على
الشركه رغم تلك الحقائق كلها لا يزال
الملياردير ينظر بتفاؤل للعصفور الازرق
ويغرد عبره بابرز انجازاته على صعيد
المستخدمين يقول ماسك ان تسجيلات
المستخدمين الجدد بلغت اعلى مستوياتها
بمتوسط اكثر من مليونين شخص يوميا في
الايام السبعه الماضيه اعتبارا من السادس
عشر من نوفمبر وبالنسبه 66 بالمئه مقارنه
بالاسبوع نفسه من العام الماضي وما يقرب
من ثمانيه مليارات دقيقه نشطه يوميا
للمستخدمين في الايام السبعه الماضيه
اعتبارا من ال 15 من نوفمبر وبالنسبه 30%
مقارنه بنفس الاسبوع من العام الماضي اما
خطاب الكراهيه على تويتر فبات بقرابه
الثلث اعتبارا من الثالث عشر من نوفمبر
مقارنه بمنتصف اكتوبر من العام الماضي
بانخفاض من 10 ملايين الى مليونين ونصف
المليون الا ان النظر تتفاؤليه لاول ماسك
تجاه منصته الرقميه كانت تناقض ارقاما
اخرى فقد كشفت تقرير لمركز مكافحه
الكراهيه الرقبيه ان استخدام الاهانات
العنصريه على تويتر ارتفع ثلاثه اضعاف
مقارنه بالاعوام السابقه منذ استحواذ الى
الماسك على المنصه واتهم الاتحاد الاوروبي
وتويتر بالفشل في ازاله خطاب الكراهيه
[موسيقى]
شكرا لك محمد باقي دقيقه ونصف تقريبا على
النهايات مباراه المانيا اسبانيا النتيجه
هدف مقابل هدف ولا لم يبقى لنا الا
التفكير بالعربي
حمله القمع الايرانيه تشتد في الداخل
وتشتاز الحدود وابنه الشقيقه العالم من
التعامل مع النظام
مباراه خطفت الانفاس
وربما تنتهي بتعادل المانيا واسبانيا بهدف
مقابل هدف والمغرب يبث الفرح
السلاح الاوكراني يدخل اوروبا
وروسيا في خطر ايضا
تركيا
وتصمم على الاستمرار والاكراد يتظاهرون
احتجاجا على الصمت الدولي
شكرا لكم على
صفحتنا على مواقع التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]